Breitbart is in trouble over the past
two months right-wing propaganda news
website Breitbart has lost 90% of its
advertisers between March and May the
number of advertisers advertising on
Breitbart drops from 242 to merely 26
and this is according to media radar
they track online advertising more than
2,200 companies have pulled their ads
from the website including outtie Harris
Teeter Ethan Allen and lyft among the
remaining advertisers I think you're
going to like this Breitbart is holding
on to the ads of a strip club in
Virginia a golf course in Spain and a
right-wing political organization called
Judicial Watch as well as a website
called big viral stories which is an
anti Hillary Clinton magazine media
radar says that now most of Breitbart
advertisers are almost exclusively just
conservative organizations and Todd crit
Suleman who's the co-founder and chief
executive of media radar said to the
Washington Post quote Breitbart
advertising has collapsed most political
sites are making less money today than
they did a year ago because of the
election cycle but they're not down
ninety percent I can guarantee that
Breitbart has not responded to requests
for comment on this specifically but
they said that it is true some staff
members have admitted that the drop in
advertisers is hurting the site Fox
Business said quote people at the news
outlets say that an effort is underway
to make Breitbart more mainstream by
hiring reporters to cover news and
devote less space to political
commentary then has been its forte
people inside Breitbart say while the
website may in fact be profitable it is
also suffering from a business
standpoint with advertising dollars
shrinking significantly the mileage
innopolis thing couldn't have been good
for Breitbart either we've done multiple
segments on the importance of
communicating to companies you care
about if their advertising dollars are
showing up in places that makes you not
want to support them people have been
doing that people have been tweeting
advertisers saying your ads
on Breitbart you might not even know it
and many companies have pulled their ads
I fully support this and people write to
me pat and they say David how can you
support this if you're getting crushed
by the YouTube ad boycott you're
supporting what's crushing you no no no
no YouTube's advertisers are not going
to YouTube saying we're offended by the
David Pakman show and don't want to
advertise on that show what happened was
as a result of a Wall Street Journal
article advertisers threatened to pull
out altogether from YouTube and YouTube
turned on an ad algorithm that
inadvertently pulled two-thirds of the
advertising from our channel this is
very different than activism by
consumers saying I will not support your
brand if you advertise on this media
outlet these are drastically different
things yeah so in their example it's
specific advertisers going after a
specific website for a specific reason
you yeah say the same about the YouTube
ad boycott and in fact it's quite the
opposite where the misunderstanding that
the YouTube ad algorithm was too relaxed
led to something going in the opposite
direction making it too strict and
systemically hurting tons of producers
and as far as I know advertisers have
not gone to YouTube and said we don't
want ads on the David Pakman show
because our audience doesn't like it to
my knowledge that's never happened you
know I wouldn't really be too happy if
advertisers pulled their content from
just a typical right-wing news source I
would probably just be indifferent about
it but Breitbart has run headlines like
Bill Kristol is a renegade Jew like
birth control makes women unattractive
in crazy sure so this isn't just the
right-wing site this is definitely the
all trite white supremacist news outlet
but they would argue Pat that those are
editorials that's not their new Oh so
therefore exactly what difference does
it make they're still choosing to run
the stuff this is being discussed on our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it join us there
talk about this or any other stories
from the show today's program is
sponsored in part by tag adapt the
hosting
specialists offering affordable and
reliable dedicated virtual private and
cloud server options as well as custom
server solutions and colocation services
in the UK tailored to your business or
project over 70% of taga dad's business
comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
a real testament to the great support
that they give their customers in case
in point they have a nine point seven
out of ten review rating on Trustpilot
which scores them as excellent you can
get a ten British Pound free credit
roughly twelve or thirteen US dollars
towards cloud server accounts at sign up
tag adapt calm /td PS check it out sign
up dot ta ga da b.com /t dps